he's a senior writer for baseball spent
many many years with the new york times
before joining the worldwide leader in
sports i saw
him last night we all did on the red sox
sweep of the yankees on sunday night
baseball he is buster olney of the
worldwide leader in sports how are you
buster
i'm doing great rich good to talk with
you good to chat with you um
before we get to i guess the main course
which is what
baseball is doing about uh all the gunk
that appears to be being placed on
baseballs we talked about it on this
show with john boy last week and
before we get to that i want to talk
about what we saw last night
on on sunday night baseball with the red
sox
sweeping the yankees what what is going
on
with the new york yankees right now bus
the worst
offense that the yankees have put out
there in our lifetime which is saying
something because of course is the
franchise which typically has had great
offenses but when you think about the
numbers
you know they start today 25th out of 30
teams and run scored
uh they have the lowest runs per game
since 1972
the lowest beam batting average since
1968
they lead the majors in hitting into
double plays they lead the majors and
outs on the bases
it's really bad and look
if we can you see the yankees boot off
the field
repeatedly by their own fans in yankee
stadium
there's no question uh it's crisis mode
time and i'm going to be really curious
to see
you know what the response of the
yankees front office to all this is and
and whether or not they dig into
possible external solutions well what
could that be
i mean wha what what could it possibly
be with an external
solution what uh i mean i guess now
would be normally the time
where you can start looking over the
steering wheel for a trade deadline and
see what could be out there but
um you know i i i don't know that's uh
so one what what blanks can you fill in
there
on that well first off i think uh if
you're brian cashman the general manager
of the yankees your priorities have to
be
improved athleticism and more
balance in what is an incredibly
right-handed hitting yankees lineup you
know historically the yankees have had
successful left-handed hitters
and somehow last night against a
right-handed starter they're rolling out
a lineup with eight right-handed hitters
so a guy to watch i think in the weeks
ahead and i don't think so get him
but i'm sure that they if they haven't
already uh gone in
into conversations about him they will
to tell marta
of the arizona diamondbacks like right
now they're not a lot of teams out and
essentially informing other teams are
ready to sell but it's a disastrous year
for the diamondbacks
uh they're in a really tough division to
tell more valued never going to be
higher than it is now he's a switch
hitter he can play center field
is it 376 and on top of that
for the yankees he actually is a really
affordable contract
um you know two team options in 2023 in
2024
um and that actually is important for
the yankees right now because to this
point how time run of their owner
has not approved the yankees going over
the competitive balance uh
threshold at 210 million dollars the
yankees payroll this year
is about where it was in 2005. so we'll
see where uh house time brother goes
with the payroll this year well i mean
if hal's dad was alive
you know what the conversation would be
about the general manager and the
manager right now i think the hitting
coach would have been already gone
um and uh and then of course the home
plate umpiring of last night's game
buster only um
where uh odor took a ball four that
would have loaded the bases in the
bottom of the ninth and instead
gabe morales called it strike three i
mean it was um
easily one of the worst calls that was
nationally televised
this year what happens with something
like that does baseball
do something about i mean i i know how
the nfl handles calls and and reviewing
it we know the nba has their
their two-minute report what happens uh
after something like that
last night in baseball nothing nothing
okay then well that's not okay but
well and i gotta say like home plate
empire last night actually had a good
night up until that call he'd been he'd
been pretty good but that was a terrible
call
um you know in the crowd cover the nfl
for one year in 2002 and it was shocking
to see the different cultures of of that
sport
versus major league baseball look
earlier this year we had repeated
mistakes made with
instant replay and there was no
acknowledgement for major league
baseball that those were mistakes were
made
so last night home plate up fire makes a
bad call
he gets a report today on the electronic
uh
you know basically evaluation of what
his game was and then it goes away
um you wish that it would change in
baseball about that
you know george steinbrenner how he
would handle these things right
and he made changes all the time in
season with managers with coaches
the yankees had not changed the manager
in season
since nineteen ninety it's a completely
different culture i think since brian
cashman
took over his gm in 98 i am going to be
curious to see at the end of this year
you know where uh you know where house
time runner goes and how is feeling
about the direction of the franchise
buster only here on the rich eisen show
let's get into
what uh you were tweeting out over the
weekend what this show has been talking
about
uh the athletic had a report sports
illustrated had a report that
pitchers are putting stuff on baseballs
uh mike schilt the manager of the st
louis cardinals essentially gave up the
ghost
uh in a post-game diatribe
to the media after country joe west made
one of his pictures
changed his hat because of seeing a spot
on
on the brim and shilt was saying you've
got to be kidding me like nobody's
checking for anything this year and we
all know
pitchers are cheating essentially is
what he was saying i'm i'm paraphrasing
so baseball is going to do something
mid-season
about all this buster there is going to
be a war
on foreign substances and it's going to
be aggressive
uh on friday major league baseball
officials
uh representatives of the union their
umpire folks on this call on a car had a
conference call on friday
where they were beginning to finalize
the details of what this is going to
look like and memo was expected to go
out to all teams later this week
and then sometime in the next week to 10
days and i think
it could be as soon as next monday
umpires will be instructed to enforce
the sports substance rule that is
already
on the books and what that's going to
entail
is repeated and random checks of
pictures and maybe even position players
if umpires see cause now uh
there are a couple of really interesting
there's so many layers this but a couple
of the ones that are really interesting
to me is
a driving force behind this conversation
now
has actually been positioned players in
the sport
they've been sending in video to central
baseball
essentially calling out peers pointing
out where they're cheating
and major league baseball in the last
two months is effectively
built scouting reports on
how different pitchers specific pitchers
uh are using foreign substances and that
information
going to be provided to umpires at the
outset of each series
like rich eisen uh you know pitcher for
the seattle pilot
likes to tug this long strings on his
glove and get pelican
grip on off of that look for that in
games
i i think the impact could be dramatic
and it's going to be front and center in
the sport
as soon as they implement that and as
they say it could be as soon as a week
from today so what happens in a game if
that happens ejections
from the game and then suspensions
afterwards yes if the umpires
uh find a foreign substance there will
be objections and what they've talked
about
and then again i as of uh you know over
the weekend this is not finalized
conversation at the owners meetings last
week was that there would be
suspension of 10 games without pay which
would be significant and in the owners
meetings
uh one owner pointed out look they're
probably file grievances but the
response was
this is too big of a problem we're
seeing offenses diminish
action diminish in the sport just go
ahead render the the
suspensions and if they grieve it fine
but you're talking about pitchers whose
names are gonna
uh moving forward will have questions
attached to them
after they are caught with foreign
substances about what their actual
skills and values are to to
you know in to teams that uh are using
them or possible future employees so
major league baseball from everything
i'm hearing he's going to be very
aggressive about that well buster only
of espn here on the rich hasn't shown
one of the things that mike shelter the
cardinals was upset about was what he
assumed what he was portraying is
something
that was arbitrary like you're checking
my guy's hat and you're not checking
everybody else
so what what is the trigger mechanism
on on inspecting a pitcher what's it
gonna be does a team ask for it a
manager asks for it or an umpire just
goes on suspicion or something like that
i mean what happens
this is going to be driven by the
umpires and then one source told me it's
going to be a lot like a dui checkpoint
um what they're going to do as they say
they're going to have information going
into a series
they see like you and i see if we were
sitting watching a ball game you and i
can see where pictures are going
to spot in their gloves uh you know
potentially on the form of their of
their gloved hand other spots reformed
substances the empire see that as well
i've had conversations with vampires
through the years where they tell me
yeah we see it
but the mandate hadn't come down from
major league baseball for them to
enforce it
that's changing and so what their you
will see
is as they mentioned probably eight to
ten
uh random checks through the course of
the game or if they see something and
they want to act on it
and because they're cognizant of pace of
play issues
some of those checks are going to happen
as the pitcher leaves
the mound after an inning or an
appearance so let's say you know rich
eisen
uh throws the the top of the first
inning and they suspect you of a foreign
substance you will be intercepted on
your way back to the dugout
and the umpire will say show me your
gloves show me your hat
show me your belt show me those strings
hanging off your glove
and they will act so somebody's
literally gonna
you're right let's just sound like
you're at the tsa checkpoint
and uh unless i guess you got clear you
know what i mean
and and that may be the problem i guess
so
wow the opposing up the the the manager
of the pitcher that's being checked
isn't gonna go totally nuts
on the spot that somebody throws an
immaculate inning they're feeling good
this is gonna happen in a playoff game
buster you know like
the one thing that you know with the nfl
whenever they changed an
uh uh what they would call uh an
emphasis
uh a rules emphasis an emphasis on the
rules
in the middle of a season coaches go
crazy but
i guess baseball could not do uh what
they were planning to do which is
use this year's an inspection year any
longer when
you know players are starting to talk
about it and we're also
seeing it and you know half of major
league baseball starting lineups
aren't even hitting 200. and i guess is
that
is that the crisis point that people are
talking about it and
and the forget about pace of play i
guess you're not worried about pace of
play anymore if somebody's removing
their belt
in the two minutes that that you have in
commercial break right
buster exactly exactly and the parallel
to the steroid era are unbelievable
uh look at the beginning you know in the
early nineties you talk to players who
were clean and they
you know they kind of were curious about
you know what they saw tony gwynn
telling me about going into the oakland
athletics weight room and seeing what
the oakland players like in sacramento
lifting being wow
he that something and then in the mid
nineties it was man there are a lot of
players using this and by two thousand
two thousand
one clean players or players who wanted
to be clean
were getting angry because they realized
it was a zero-sum competition
and if players were having an advantage
and they uh were not
by using pd's then essentially money was
being taken out of their pockets
and that's exactly where we are where i
think the position players
have realized you know what pictures are
completely dominating and you know who's
paying the price for that
we are as hitters which is why you've
got players
sending in video to central baseball
saying
look at what this picture is doing look
at the spot on his glove
look at how he's doing this uh and that
is absolutely the driving force be
behind why major league baseball's
acting quickly and
as you know baseball is not a sport that
typically acts quickly we just talked
about
you know umpires making mistakes during
the course of the year they don't really
do anything
but in this case with offense down
position players complaining
they are acting all right and uh last
one i guess when when again
do we see this do we see this by the
middle of this month and all of a sudden
you might see pitchers who who have uh
nine-figure contracts
and spin rates through the roof suddenly
give up a ton of runs
is that really what we're might be
seeing buster and in the last
week players are watching spin rates
and they're noting it you know josh
donaldson made a comment about garrett
cole spin rate going down trevor bauer's
spin rate was down
over the weekend uh yes
i was told that perhaps as soon as june
14th
you will see umpires begin to do this at
the latest within two weeks
it's going to be immediate and let's
face it you know knuckleheads like me
are going to be doing a lot of before
and after
when we look at the statistics for
pitchers for position players for
offenses
once umpires start to be aggressive with
these checks buster you're the man
thanks for the call
greatly appreciate it let's do this uh
let's do the after this is the before
let's do the after in a couple weeks
appreciate it that sounds like fun rach
all right
you got it it's buster olney sunday
night baseball reporters espn senior
rider right here
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here